hi I'm Scott McCartney travel columnist
at The Wall Street Journal I'm here to
give you some tips on flying to the
other side of the world in a seat like
this and I'll be testing my tips on the
longest airline flight ever taking off
from Newark New Jersey and landing in
Singapore I'm in Newark ready to go on
the longest flight in the world I'm
feeling good now let's see what it's
like when I get there on an aircraft
humidity levels are 20% or less for
reference a comfortable level is 40 to
50 percent this dries out your mouth
skin and everything else it can cause
fatigue headaches bad breath muscle and
joint aches so drink up and think about
your food choices pick items with higher
water content for example Singapore
Airlines has replaced potatoes with
riced cauliflower and one of my favorite
tips brings saline solution to keep your
nose moist and eye drops to keep your
eyes moist put them in a baggie that you
can store in the seat back pocket so you
have easy access tip number two clean
your seat
dehydration dries out the mucous
membranes in your nose which trap
unwanted germs without them you're more
likely to catch things from your fellow
passengers but unlike what you might
think sickness isn't spread through the
airplanes circulating air supply its
surfaces you need to watch out for so
embrace your inner germaphobe and wipe
down your armrest and tray table and
seat back and breathe easier knowing
that modern airplanes have advanced air
filtration systems that trap germs and
bacteria almost to operating room
standards so open that air vent to full
blast and aim it at your nose that's the
cleanest air you're gonna get tip 3 move
depending on your airline you may be
only looking at 31 or 32 inches of space
and coach which is awfully tight for a
long flight
rather than being comfortable get up
frequently if you don't there are side
effects like decrease blood flow which
can increase the chances of blood clots
try sending an alarm on your phone for 3
hours into your flight if you haven't
gotten up and moved yet it's time to
stand drink some tea or coffee well they
will dehydrate you they have the benefit
of being diuretics which will force you
to get up and go to the bathroom and
exercise some airlines including
Singapore are putting exercise videos in
the entertainment system things you can
do while sitting down to increase blood
flow tip 4 adjust your body clock jetlag
starts in the air the cause of this
common problem is that your circadian
rhythm gets mixed up causing fatigue
headaches difficulty concentrating and
even nausea so try setting your watch to
the local time right after takeoff
that'll help you know when to eat and
sleep during the flight on a very long
flight getting at least some sleep is
important and airlines will help with
this by dimming the lights and lowering
the temperature in the cabin at ideal
times for sleep so take their cues just
about everybody to see but sleep is
personal
so do what's best for you for me that's
earplugs an ambien tip 5 limit the booze
alcohol both dehydrates you and messes
with your circadian rhythm this is kind
of a perfect storm for a long flight but
this is one of the pleasures of travel
so take advantage if you want just not
too much
do all that and you should hopefully
walk off the airplane feeling as good as
possible
I must the plane after more than 18
hours legs are a little shaky I didn't
get much sleep pulled an all-nighter but
I'm actually feeling better than I
thought this is the new way of travel
and it's gonna take some adjusting for
people you're gonna have to get in the
right frame of mind to take on this
marathon and you're gonna have to make
some preparations that really will make
a difference
[Music]